hello Tiny Tim hello oh but it looks
even worse when I see
this mr. Norton I'm so excited about
your Christmas show but Sir there there
be that's all you've got bar you can't
if you not drive at all no but do you
know what I've seen people do it you
can't drink and drive so what's the
point
that's sort of why I learned I can't
drink not worth it
both rebel and bad have talked about
working with you Ricki and that it's
quite annoying not for me well what they
mean is I don't know what I mean they
probably just mean I'm annoying you're
annoying
that's like happens like every four
seconds no it's fine it's so much fun to
work with Ricky because he does up a lot
and what happens is we start doing these
scenes and we start improvising and
he'll start to laugh and sometimes you
think oh he's laughing it's something
funny I did but usually he's laughing
it's something funny he did I know this
because sometimes we'll start the scene
and nobody said anything he'll start to
laugh that's because he's laughing it's
something funny that he thought of a
picture of you in your pop career
yeah that is a curious eyebrow that is
well what's going on over there
what's along with that that two-piece
what is that that's called Shauna
dancing let's move on what's see I know
what you're doing you're going oh look
at you that you know I'm not embarrassed
by that I'm embarrassed by this yeah
well I collect stuff from movies that
some of the movies I've done but really
mainly Star Trek memorabilia cuz I love
Star Trek never been in a Star Trek but
I love the original series so I have
like I have the Gorn head from the
original series from the episode arena
where
what the Gorn is the Gorn from Star Trek
we're gonna give you the gold you have a
lovely way of using social media as a
tribute to your partner Jane yeah I just
yeah I like you're in the bar faces that
you do I get the bar faces but then I
also get pictures with we were out or
something I I sort of like lag behind
and get Jane by herself with no and I
take a picture of her and I tweet Jane
with all their friends
I don't know how funny Jane finds these
so here's one you choose of Jane Jane
thought you've made a new friend but it
was just a shot what you're describing
Jane thinking about making new friends
[Laughter]
where is he where is it he sees the
tweet is Jane is looking so happy
because her new friend hasn't walked
away yet when you're when she's posing
for one of these pictures does she go is
this one of those pictures where you're
gonna make me look like I have no know
there had to be there had been a few
words at home after you posted this one
just found this photo of Jane when she
was little
[Laughter]
thirty years is it true the story about
getting the call from Stephen Hawking
yeah yeah well I I did I got a call from
this guy how'd you know it was him yeah
I really loved the idea of being
surrounded by exotic animals so in my
house I have like a zebra and I have a
giraffe as well
Wow but not like a real one but like oh
it was real before natural like the flu
you got high ceilings down in your house
very
always drinking drinking animals they
just
the time today but it's not funny
Russian accent hell are your balls my
balls I don't know how that happened he
just it just morphed into why I'd have
to be Russian he'd come to work and go
and here comes mr. Bendele with his big
balls with this suspicious round ball
yeah but not Russian accent that's it he
had to play America and I didn't want to
play American I made Kelly with I'll
play America never was America except me
I just wrote in these from reading
I never knew you were this weird I'm so
worried that I am the only one that's
made it along with that growing up in my
family it was like everyone was winding
everyone up I was the youngest of like
four and I remember once when my sister
um she must have been about I don't know
25 or something I was like eight and
they just they turn out in the woods and
I used to be followed you know still of
insects I know about spice and
everything and I found a perfect little
discarded snakeskin and I picked it up
and my sister was scared of it and I
certainly thought oh I've got her and I
was teasing and she was gonna put it
down it's got germs right and I was
running around chasing her and she went
you're not coming the car with that so
eventually I left it there and then when
I was about 15 I was at home with my
lights I decided to wind her up when I
was I started teasing her about and she
was scared of snakes I texted with a
snake skin and she chose that time to
tell me but I've actually been running
around with a used condom
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]